the 2 400 kilometer long himalayas
include the highest peaks beautiful
landscapes
and some of the most contentious areas
in the world
the mountainous region separates two
rising super powers
that contain over a third of the
planet's population
and there's a big problem it's not well
demarcated
they're not signposts everywhere it's
not even very well populated very few
people live up there
it's very tricky to have a sense of
who's controlling
what bits of that very long border and
it's very easy for
accidents to happen boundary
disagreements led to a deadly military
clash between the two sides for the
first
time since 1975
[Music]
adding to the border disputes is china's
belton road initiative
a massive infrastructure project aimed
at spreading beijing's influence
all over the globe including countries
which are at odds with india
we know that pakistan is a big part of
china's
belt and road initiative we know that
china has been investing in
ports they've been investing in roads in
pakistan and india and pakistan do share
a very contentious relationship
also in response to all of this
india has increased military on the
border banned chinese apps
and improved ties with strategic
partners to try and prevent the spread
of chinese influence
india believes that china wants a
unipolar
asia that is dominated by china where
china sets the rules of the road
and where countries acquiesce to chinese
needs and wants while a war may be
unlikely
china has made it known it aims to take
back what it sees as its territory
xi jinping has made it his goal to
put china what he says is the center
stage of the world
and he's also said you know he wants
china to stand tall in the world i think
with that sort of rhetoric it leaves
very little room for china to be able to
maneuver
and give concessions
the late 1940s saw china's communists
overthrow the ruling government
to form what it is today the people's
republic of china the hero of the
revolution
was mao zedong that same decade india
gained independence from great britain
to create their current democratic
government
india was one of the first countries to
recognize the people's republic of china
and they did have
the first few years where india and
china really
did partner with each other and saw each
other's countries that
could move forward together there was a
little bit of an asia for asians or
india china brothers kind of atmosphere
or at least friends but that didn't last
long
shortly after establishing the people's
republic of china
the government exerted its control over
tibet
during the revolution in which the
chinese communist party
took control of the country in the late
50s they then sent
troops into tibet to take control of
that region which had been
semi-autonomous semi-independent up
until that point as a result of that the
dalai lama
in 1959 fled to india took refuge in
india
the dalai lama declared that his escape
would not have been possible
without the loyal support of his people
although they'd signed an agreement
meant for both sides to respect each
other's territorial integrity
india and china began to confront each
other on the border
china became convinced then that not
only
was india at fault for accepting the
dalai lama and these refugees
but also accused india of actually
colluding with the u.s
and the uk to engineer his escape
and so by the early 60s you really saw a
relationship where there was very little
trust and a sense that the agreement
had essentially kind of broken down or
as far as india was concerned was not
being
respected by beijing
the first skirmishes took place when
india discovered china had been building
roads through what it viewed as its
territory
and just a few years later the most
significant border conflict occurred
the point at which india and china sort
of disputes really
reached their climax was in 1962 when
the two sides fought a war
over the same territory that they're
fighting over now up in the himalayas
thousands died on both sides with china
reaching its goal
of retaining a large area of land near
northwestern india
called aksai chin since then
there have been numerous conflicts along
what's now the longest disputed border
on the planet
the areas of contention the northwestern
himalayan region known as ladakh
the doklam plateau a territory that
intersects
china bhutan and india
[Music]
and arunachal pradesh the eastern
territory in india that china claims is
part of southern tibet
there have been borders drawn up by
various british cartographers in the
past
there's the arda johnson line marking
the border in ladakh
the mccartney mcdonald line another
proposed marking in ladakh
and the mcmahon line which marks the
border of arunachal pradesh
we have a definite cartographic vision
about our boundaries based on what the
british has thought about
it's based on a little bit of geography
little bit of ethnicity a little bit of
history
so it's a very well defined boundaries
which has not been recognized by china
although some british drawn lines were
agreed upon by past governments in tibet
they were never formally accepted by
beijing
and this is precisely where the clash is
because
there's no settled line at the moment
where both agree especially in these
disputed areas in the north and the east
where the actual border lies
but there have been many periods since
the 1962 war
where there wasn't conflict
what they did between 1993 and
2012 2013 in the two decade period
they set up a series of agreement which
essentially established that
a lot of those territories that both
countries claim
would be both man's land so to speak
neither side
would disturb the status quo both sides
would get to patrol
those regions and both sides would not
establish a permanent presence in the
region
this solution is known as the line of
actual control
and it's a temporary border where both
sides maintain the status quo
but even that line's location isn't
fully agreed upon
in 2013 a dispute occurred in the dem
chok valley near ladakh
and another in 2015 where indian
soldiers destroyed a chinese-built
structure in what they saw as their
territory
then things really started to heat up
near the dockland plateau
there was one boundary crisis in 2017
where it actually involved the boundary
dispute between
china and bhutan which again it's not
quite demarcated but there's an
understanding
about it india as an ally of bhutan got
involved
to help push china back or get it to
reverse its movement
or its unilateral change of the status
quo there
china brought heavy road building
equipment into the disputed region
and began constructing a road one that
would give china a direct route to the
siliguri corridor
or chicken's neck where all land-based
military and commercial traffic
travel between india's north-eastern
provinces and the rest of the country
so if there ever is a war or major
conflict
between china and india this would be
strategically significant land
bhutan allowed india's military to enter
their country to stop the construction
for months the troops faced off but no
casualties were reported
after that incident india and china
appeared to have put their differences
behind them
china's relationship with india that had
sort of looked
promising as recently as 2019 xi jinping
traveled to india
had this two-day summit with modi and
just before that modi came to
china and had a multi-day summit with xi
jinping here
the two countries were sort of finding a
common ground where they could work
together
india and china had actually established
economic ties were perhaps
at their greatest point in history
china had become india's largest trading
partner but you also saw chinese
investment for the first time going into
india
in a significant way and china was
seeking
to enter in an even bigger way and
particularly in india's
telecommunication sector and the 5g
network
then in 2020 the pandemic happened
the breaking news is about the confirmed
corona virus
in kerala where a student studying in
china's wuhan university has tested
positive with the deadly virus
because of china's handling of kovid
india started becoming concerned
about its over dependence on china and
certain sectors
the lack of transparency if certain
chinese companies
their links with the state and whether
the chinese state would use
its economic ties for whether it was
coercion
or economic influence
up until this point most of the
standoffs had been non-violent because
of agreements between both sides not to
use firearms
the majority of the confrontations
during the 20th century
used loudspeakers to taunt each other
from far away chinese troops have
set up loudspeakers that belt out
punjabi numbers at their forward posts
let's take a look
but soon after the pandemic broke out
the border confrontations turned deadly
in may 2020 china surprised india by
deploying troops in the disputed region
of ladakh
and pakistani occupied kashmir
china says india's recent construction
of roads
tunnels and the refurbishment of
airfields in the area along the border
changed the status quo and forced china
to respond
after weeks of skirmishes 20 indian
soldiers and at least four chinese
soldiers
died in hand-to-hand combat and it came
at a time when economic relations
between the two countries were at its
peak
this is a question that continues to
baffle
a number of experts who focus both on
china and india
why would beijing essentially put at
stake
a relationship with india that has been
growing in importance and that china has
in part pursued
to keep a country like india away from
its main adversary the u.s
why would china put this at risk and the
answers
that we have had are kind of twofold
one they believed that this was a
tactically
significant pieces of territory and that
they did not anticipate the backlash
from india
they thought like in other parts of asia
that they would essentially establish
their claims then
india would accept that and that they
would go back to business as usual
although the confrontation ended
building along the border didn't
in early 2021 china completed the
construction of a new village high in
the mountains near the dockland plateau
called pangda
the latest addition to a handful of
villages china has built to fortify the
tibetan borderlands
but there's another problem some of
these villages are located inside land
claimed by bhutan it's the classic
possession
is nine tenths of the law phenomena it
is china's saying
we're just going to change facts on the
ground establish a presence
and the idea has been that nobody will
push back
experts refer to their tactic as salami
slicing
and it reflects the widest strategy of
china's leader xi jinping
to assert the country's territorial
claims in small steps
while not addressing it head on
china's overall strategy for a lot of
things and i'm extrapolating at this
point to include the order
is to try and push questions that cannot
be resolved today
into the future and the thought behind
that is that
any issue that china has to tackle today
if it can tackle it
in five ten years down the road china
will be in a stronger position at that
point
china's end goal is unknown but
considering the sparsely populated
inaccessible areas along the border the
reasons for claiming new territory
seem to be less about wanting the land
for economic or strategic
military reasons there are
other explanations of which the primary
one
is that xi jinping and the communist
party of china
wants to prove to their own public that
even though they had made some missteps
at home in terms of handling kovid they
could help take over these territories
or establish
their presence in territories that china
claims on their sovereignty grounds and
so essentially this was a
nationalism argument
china's obviously become much more
assertive in its territorial claims i
think a lot of people have talked about
this
wolf warrior diplomacy where chinese
diplomats
are much more aggressive and verbally
defending rhetorically defending china's
position
china's obviously backed that up with
more military spending
but you've also seen it reflected in
chinese state media
they go to greater lengths to celebrate
chinese military accomplishments
they go to greater lengths to show that
uh chinese territorial claims are being
upheld and defended
in the south china sea few are willing
to fight back china's claims
but india is different the problems in
the south china sea including a number
of different claimants who are
smaller perhaps not willing or able to
take
china on those don't relate to the china
in this situation
where india has the ability to hold its
ground
although india lags behind china in
terms of military
technology and infrastructure it may be
one of the few countries willing to
contest china in the region
india has already opposed china's belton
road initiative
which some estimate involves as much as
eight trillion dollars
aimed at creating economic ties all over
the globe
it was one of the first major countries
to announce that it was going to boycott
the first belton road forum
and it does not do so because it says
that it does not respect
standards like financial sustainability
environmental sustainability
uh transparency and territorial
integrity that last bit
is important for india and one of the
key reasons it does not
subscribe to the belton road initiative
india believes that china through its
china-pakistan economic corridor
has established projects in what india
considers disputed territory between
india and pakistan it's likely that
india will continue to
boycott the belton road initiative for
the near future
china's handling of kovid the border
crisis and the belton road
have all led india to look elsewhere for
economic ties
determined to become less reliant on
china
after the 2020 flare-ups india banned
dozens of chinese apps
and prime minister modi doubled down on
the quad an association of four
democracies
australia japan india and the us
committed to preventing the indo-pacific
from becoming beijing's geopolitical
domain
it's cemented a group of strong
democracies that will
work together going forward to secure a
free and open indo-pacific
and this is great news for the us who's
looked to increase ties with india for
decades
u.s policy makers have seen india as a
geopolitical counterbalance an economic
alternative
and a democratic contrast to china
even if it's not an ally and the fact
that it does have a rivalry with china
that china would have to dedicate a
certain amount of its own
resources uh in defending against india
or in tackling india
and so that in and of itself could uh
help with the balance of power
uh in the indo-pacific and therefore
they have also talked about
not just approving of india's rise that
it is in u.s national security interest
to support india's rise
if you look at india the pace of growth
the size of the population
it's a huge market you have chinese
companies like
tok huawei all of which thought they
were going to have
big businesses in india and that's
obviously changed in the recent past
although india has a history of
non-alignment dating back from the cold
war
the intense standoff in recent years may
have finally pushed them to choose sides
the u.s and india have a lot to gain if
they can hold the line against china
and much to lose if they can't
i think the the chinese do see as the
greater issue here
india sort of forming this alliance with
the us joining the quad
i think beijing is calibrating its
response to the borders dispute
to try and to defend its territorial
claims but also not to do
so much that it pushes india into the
american embrace we will work together
closer than ever before the best case
scenario for how this plays out between
india and china is they resolve the
border dispute
they pull their troops back trade
resumes
but i think that that is also a very
unlikely outcome
given the recent indian participation in
the quad
given how much effort the u.s has put in
to strengthening that relationship and
how poorly the relationship between
china and the u.s has gone
it does seem unlikely that india and
china are going to have
happy days anytime soon
you